B of Ramsey solutions Sarah is with us
hi Sarah how are you I'm good Dave how
are you welcome welcome where do you
live
Indianapolis good for you and you're
here to do your debt-free scream I am
yes love it how much have you paid off a
hundred and six thousand dollars Oh
how long did that take you two years and
two months way to go
making what kind of money started off at
sixty seven thousand dollars ended
around one hundred twenty seven thousand
way to go what do you do
veterinarian ah very nice love it love
it so what kind of debt I'm guessing vet
school bills all student loans from vet
school yes and so what happened two
point two years ago that allowed you to
years two months ago that started you on
this journey graduated from vet school
okay and said okay I gotta address this
yes I wanted to attack it immediately
what made you think you should and could
do that you know I grew up my parents
blessed me with those principles growing
up about you know never getting into
debt paying off debt as soon as possible
the student loans and so it wasn't an
option for me to just have that as a pet
for 10 to 20 years no pun intended as a
veterinary we can't have a student loan
as a pet if your veterinarian
particularly yeah that's pretty good I
love it
so dad came with you or he met you here
he did yeah and my mom is starting a new
job so she couldn't be here but she's
watching so he's proud and here to cheer
young yep very fun I love it so what
happened during this two years and two
months you can't you grew up with these
values you get out of school you start
making some decent money and you decided
we're gonna get in real attack mode tell
me what happened you know not much
actually I just continued to live like a
college student the whole time the
hardest part was seeing all my
classmates you know starting to buy
houses buy new cars all these things
because they're making decent money but
I continued to to live the lifestyle
that I had been so really it wasn't hard
for me in terms of learning new habits
but it was hard watching some of the
things I felt like I was missing out on
mm-hmm area and how did you intersect
with our material I actually
my last year of med school I took a
business rotation actually and we all
had to read a different business book
and your entree leadership book was
actually part of that and I randomly
selected it and I started reading at
night immediately was gravitated towards
your principles it's biblical you know
everything that I had grown up with
mm-hmm and so then I got hooked on to
your show and then read your Total Money
Makeover book as well okay very cool and
so that gave you the the game plan to go
with the value system and the income and
then you got an attack mode exactly you
helps me really outline the steps that I
needed to take I knew the general
principles but that was a huge help
people make fun of you living on nothing
yes there's lots of jokes I'm pretty
good at laughing at myself too so it
wasn't too hard going through that but
kind of the the worst so that it would
be oh you're a cheapskate you know
you're making decent money but it broke
people are making fun of your financial
plan you're right on track Yeah right
that's good way to go
well congratulations thank you what do
you tell people the key to paying off a
hundred and six thousand in two years in
two months you know you you have to want
it so many young professionals you know
who are different what are their
veterinarians physicians they they don't
want to get out of debt it's something
that our society uses as normal and so
you really have to want it if you don't
want it you're never going to have the
discipline to to get out of debt it kind
of has to become this all-consuming
thing for a short period of time doesn't
it it does it was my my complete Drive
in focus during the past few years so
how's it feel now so liberating and just
that overwhelming sense of peace about
it I wouldn't trade any of the past few
years at all for this feeling why we
call it financial peace factly two words
that don't go together like airline
service way to go very proud of you
all right Sara from Indianapolis a
hundred and six thousand dollars paid
off in two years and two months making
sixty-seven up to 127 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
way to go very very very cool man that
is fun